yes yes yes yes hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome back down now
we just got done with spending the night
with Lola here and I read self-help
books all the time I sure do
I sure do I don't know why I'm still
lying to you but I sure do and your
birthday February 20 I actually like
Lola I look a little a lot let's see
where you get it sports I don't like to
read okay so now we need to start making
progress through the other girls because
we are currently standing at Celeste is
at four but I'm gonna save her I haven't
been on a date with Nikki I've only been
on one with Tiffany Kiana
Audrey's close but Audrey's up I guess
mmm let's see oh that everyone's at the
beach so I guess I guess I could go with
Audrey because I don't get that one out
of the way so that I can live my life
and be happy with the other choices that
I've made in my existence and hopefully
hopefully I will be able to go home with
a nice girl who just happens to not be
you I will make it very quick as fast as
I can I just want this goddamn date to
be over can you shut shut up shut up
shut up shut up just go on the date I'll
match my puzzle pieces you'll go ooh ah
you're not that great and then we'll all
just be happy with their lives is that
gonna be okay exactly to be fine yeah oh
no boy it's so bad for you and let me
solve my puzzle I need to concentrate on
getting worse at this
yeah I did I had a date okay now that
the dates over please leave as fast as
possible and don't say anything to me I
know I wasn't that good but just give me
one more date and then I will be that
good god you're so annoying you why do I
have to concur yeah I couldn't that is
the weirdest way to say that I'm sorry
you don't deserve that you don't deserve
that at all I'm going to go say hi hi I
need to do something else keyonna later
loser I need to go say hi to Kiana who's
actually nice and who you were yelling
at before and therefore I am going to be
nice to her even though I went four
hours to the same Beach that I was just
that you need to unwind with this you're
welcome
Taichi hairstyle I don't know what that
means but I like it can I get the Tai
Chi
Tai Chi I don't know how to do that oh
oh cool I actually didn't know that I
could do that I thought this hairstyle
was actually on someone else I'm okay
with this I like this one this is nice
yeah okay nevermind let's go on the day
for real yeah oh you're fine right now
okay bye then
okay she seemed really excited to be on
a date so I have high prospects for this
one that's gonna be good literally
already in a bikini
oh no no no I can't fail
I can't fit I cannot fail oh he's giving
me nothing
oh he's giving me absolutely nothing the
whole time oh my god I clutched that oh
I'm so happy I'm happier than when I
actually got laid in the game oh man
you want a tissue box to mop up your
tears ran how close that was to a bad
day oh man oh just curious how I won a
horribly horribly poorly
see if you can answer this what's my age
you're 20 okay goodbye actually no I
need to get some honey I need to get
some honey or else I'm never gonna be
able to win this there's tons and tons
and tons and tons and tons and tons of
food for your face okay
now we're doing better so let's see
Audrey's not gonna be there for the
evening
Nicki I have known men so let's just
still there I guess we can go on another
day with mom oh that would be fun I hope
that's gonna be a good time I can't wait
for that to happen
oh boy Momo ready your masters coming
back home I'm not good I had a better
day before I got home oh look more
things
aha look I can almost fit this whole
thing in practice makes perfect
lol maybe next time there will be you
Yeah right
oh that's not bad
wait did I get that picture already no I
don't want to say I've seen something if
I haven't seen is list let's just skip
the small talk let's get right to the
date yeah we're going right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah before I change my
mind and regret what I've done
wouldn't wouldn't other patron little
unethical for you to be wearing fur but
I guess cats kill other creatures all
the time so I guess it's not all that
bad I guess I shouldn't criticize I sure
I won't
oh no oh no wow that was very punishing
why did that happen that was too harsh
bro too harsh I was doing so good okay
we're getting better if I actually
concentrate and don't screw everything
up I should be totally fine but then
again I have a slight pang of regret for
everything that I've done up to this
point
you're welcome moo moo-moo-moo thank ya
I'm so happy for you Momo now run along
and don't ask me to sleep with you
because I'll be forced to by the rules
of this way you were the one that was
screaming so excitedly that I asked you
out on a date
don't come at me with that attitude as
if I'm not the greatest thing you've
ever seen in your life
because I'm markiplier I am amazing no I
can tell me otherwise no one alright
next I guess I could go on another date
with Momo this is good for me this is
good
I can't wait it's another day with a cat
oh boy how are you doing I got a message
from Keanu I caught you staring at my
butt by the way you weren't even facing
away from me for one moment I thought
maybe you'd like a closer look oops did
I get something else in there too oh
okay I was very confused imagining you
were contorted into a very strange
position so never mind then that's
censored you guys have no idea anyway
let's go on a date with Kat
JDate time again okay because we're not
cats were human beings and we need to
play tennis because everyone only plays
tennis here for some reason all right
finally using my power-ups to their
proper advantage instead of just
mumbling about like a markiplier yes
it's a synonym fern stupid
well now Momo's at level 4 so that Momo
next time we go on a date with Momo at
night you know master look I'm just like
the lady in those books you have under
your bed hey human girl would you like
to go on a date season huh that's cool
thing talk about this go on a date you
humans perfectly normal and aliens in
the mix there somewhere nice outfit
why are you wearing that here alright
whatever let me show you all my moves
and I get
there we go I didn't even need to use
these - lucky lucky triple things
alright ok so I'm getting steadily
better at it because I'm actually using
my items in conjunction with what I'm
supposed to be oh you don't care about
this at all not what huniepop sebat it's
back in the ladies are getting the
ladies getting the ladies is about
getting the ladies probably ok time to
talk to Audrey time to go on my big date
with Audrey time to go on a fun time
with Audrey maybe if I get her drunk
she'll shut up - I wish I was right now
it would be pretty cool yeah it's cool
stuff huh cool stuff let me put this
underwear sorry I've just got I'm
carrying all these pieces of underwear
around don't mind me I'm not weird
lemons popcorn good whatever just go
today with me yeah yeah okay I'm gonna
get my hopes up because I know the game
mechanics I know how this works you're
gonna be compelled to be seduced by me
yes Wow how did I get 15 cent oh that's
right you get bonus sentiment if she's
drunk I forgot about that that's an
interesting thing that's not in real
life
this is just abysmal this is by far the
worst setup I've had it's giving me
absolutely dick it's not putting things
where it's supposed to be it's not doing
things this is the first time I'm
actually complaining about the game
mechanics because it's wool there we go
done done one move left
god damn skin rough but I haven't lost
yet and she was straight there we go
thank you guys I've earned it that's how
it works with you all right I mean if
you don't know that's how it goes I
guess it's a reward will be doled out
now please just don't talk Markson if I
don't tell me you have never done a
sense oh I've done no I haven't done a
cat yet so let's not go there
hi I'm a [ __ ] yes sex with your pen is
not good could you not could you not do
that could you not do those things
you're doing right now I love any night
please stop
but the pen is inside of my button P oh
well that's rather subdued even though
you're still naked and you have to be
censored but oh great we did a thing I'm
so proud of us do you what oh ok so back
and forth a little bit maybe a little
bipolar you are well too bad I'm never
talking to you again
I only did that because I was obligated
to so thank you
and thank you everybody for watching I
will see wait thank you so much for
watching I'm almost losing my voice from
having so much fun playing this game and
being outraged to seeing that horrible
horrible picture that the cat showed me
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always